♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT HAS NOT RELEASED
ITS DECISION IN HIS HOTLY
ANTICIPATED ABORTION CASE.
THAT HAS NOT STOPPED THE LEFT
FROM THREATENING VIOLENCE IF
THEY DON'T GET THEIR PREFERRED
OUTCOME AND TODAY WHEN
NANCY PELOSI WAS ACTUALLY ASKED
DIRECTLY WHETHER DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR RHETORIC IS TO BLAME FOR
THE THREATS AND THE
ASSASSINATION PLOT, FOR EXAMPLE,
AGAINST JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, SHE
DODGED THE QUESTION, SPEWED MORE
ABORTION ALARMISM.
WHAT KIND OF ANSWER IS THIS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AS FAR AS THE ABORTION CASE
IS CONCERNED, THERE HAS BEEN A
NUMBER OF ATTACKS ON CHURCHES,
PREGNANCY CENTERS.
REPUBLICANS ARE BLAMING
DEMOCRATS FOR NOT SAYING
ANYTHING AND THEY ARE SAYING
THAT YOUR RHETORIC IS CONTRIBUTE
INTO THESE ATTACKS.
>> LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
A WOMAN HAS A RIGHT TO CHOOSE,
TO LIVE UP TO HER
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S UP TO HER, HER DOCTOR, HER
FAMILY, HER HUSBAND, HER
SIGNIFICANT OTHER, AND HER GOD.
THIS TALK OF POLITICIZING ALL OF
THIS I THINK IS SOMETHING
UNIQUELY AMERICAN AND NOT RIGHT.
>> Sean: IS IT HARD TO CONDEMN
THE RHETORIC -- IS IT HARD TO
CONDEMN THE HARASSMENT, THE
INTIMIDATION?
NOT REALLY.
BY THE WAY, WE STILL HAVEN'T
HEARD A SINGLE WORD FROM
JOE BIDEN ABOUT THE ATTEMPTED
ASSASSINATION OF A SITTING
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
KEEP IN MIND, THESE ARE THE SAME
DEMOCRATS THAT WERE SILENT ABOUT
THE 574 RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF
2020.
THEY WERE EITHER QUIET OR THE
SAME ONES THAT WERE OUT THERE
SAYING OH, NO, THEY ARE MOSTLY
PEACEFUL.
THEY ARE ONLY OBSESSING OVER ONE
RIOT THAT WE SAW ON JANUARY 6.
IF THE SAME ONES THEY REFUSE TO
ASK WHY THE PRESIDENT AUTHORIZED
THE NATIONAL GUARD TO BE
DEPLOYED UP TO 20,000 TROOPS AND
NANCY PELOSI, CHUCK SCHUMER,
SERGEANT OF ARMS -- AND BY THE
WAY, THE CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF,
THEY NEVER WERE GIVEN AN ANSWER.
ALTHOUGH MURIEL BOWSER PUT IT IN
WRITIN